hello and welcome you to this video
playing too deep for me okay too deep
from me okay so get a ratty opening
Reggie gambit very solid line here for
black the sugar 3 now is mostly played
and then she takes this is extremely
solid for black very difficult for white
to play for anything on anything special
that will see 256 bit unkind but you can
do that usually you put it on a seven
it's a bit more Simone years on you send
as it allows 98 2d6 let me know where
now it's not possible to use I'm okay so
maybe five to the work so the parent
before in some cases night a 45 these
are the typical ideas move I don't
understand
the move was too deep for me in some way
so well i mean i can take this pawn also
besides a anything else so i just took
the pawn okay so I need to make sure
that I have the Beehive square yeah but
well if I do this where's the Queen
going now but now I can take him in and
play knight c6 black resigned yeah your
night the eighth wasn't really really
bad more I think it's the chart analysis
someone the software does not react to
know it does okay yeah it was a
completely are equal position but then
he played them pretty much inexplicable
night b8 that gives white zone yeah at
least a little something the engine just
says knight c6 and equal well me but the
total bishop pair two bishops against
two lights it's always a bit tricky at
the moment that doesn't really look like
all that much because the Black Knights
are well centralized and especially the
bishop on the tool doesn't look very
frightening but in the long run this is
always going to be slightly tricky may
be here 94s ended and suggest is always
ok for black yeah but that would have
been better him here I just win a seven
absolutely nothing and now after this
should be too I've got everything nicely
secured and here Queen c7 was that when
you move to keep the material but it is
already a very bad position I can also
simply do this I mean the computer wants
to play something more complicated but
this is some a huge advantage little
oops sorry everything this is a funny
reply but okay I can watch the engine
suggest is simply good I've got a pawn
I've got the file I've got to two
bishops so that's great yeah everything
was ok there until he blundered 87
basically yeah ok guys thanks for
watching